I am writing this under depreciable
mental strain since by tonight I shall
be no more penniless and at the end of
my supply of the drug which alone makes
life endurable I can bear the torture no
longer and shall cast myself from his
Garret window into the squalid street
below do not think from my slavery to
morphing that I am a weakling or
degenerate once you have read these
hastily scrawled pages you may guess
they'll never fully realize why it is I
must have forgetfulness or death it was
in one of the most open and least
frequented parts for the broad Pacific
at the packet of which I was super cargo
fell victim to the German sea Raider the
Great War then was at its very beginning
and the ocean forces of the Hun had not
completely sunk to their later
degradation so that our vessel was a
legitimate prize whilst we offer crew
were treated of all of the fairness and
consideration do us as naval prisoners
so liberal indeed was a discipline of
our captors that five days after we were
taken I managed to escape alone in a
small boat with water and provisions for
a good length of time when I finally
found myself adrift and free I had but
little idea of my surroundings never a
competent navigator I could only guess
vaguely by the Sun in the Stars that I
was somewhere south of the equator of
the longitude I knew nothing when no
island or coastline was in sight and the
weather kept fair and for uncounted days
I drifted aimlessly beneath the
scorching Sun waiting either for some
part in ship or to be cast unto the
shores or some habitable land but
neither ship nor land appeared and I
began to despair my solitude upon the
heathen vastness of unbroken blue the
change happened whilst I slept its
details I shall never know for my
slumber though troubled and dream
infested was continuous
well at last I awaked it was to discover
myself sucked into a slimy expanse of
hellish black mire which extended about
me monotonous undulations as far as I
could see and in which my boat lay
grounded some distance away the one
might well imagine that my first
sensation would be of wonder I had so
prodigious an unexpected transformation
of scenery I was in reality more
horrified than astonished for those in
the air and the rotting soil a sinister
quality that chilled me to the very core
the region was putrid of the carcasses
of decaying fish and other less
describable things which I saw
protruding from the nasty mud of the
unending plain perhaps I should not hope
to convey in mere words the unutterable
hideousness that can dwell in absolute
silence and barren immensity there was
nothing within hearing and nothing of
insight save a reach of black slime yet
the very completeness of the stillness
and the homogeneity of the landscape
oppressed me with a nauseating fear the
Sun was blazing down from a sky which
seemed to me almost black in cloudiness
and Kranti as there reflect in the inky
marsh beneath my feet as I crawled into
the stranded boat I realized that only
one theory could explain my position
through some unprecedented volcanic
upheaval a portion of the ocean floor
must have been thrown to the surface
exposing regions which for innumerable
millions of years had lain hidden under
the unfathomable watery depths so great
was the extent of the new land which had
risen beneath me that I could not detect
the faintest noise of the surgeon ocean
strain my ears as I might normally NEC
fell to prey upon the dead things for
several hours I sat there thinking or
brooded in the boat which lay upon its
side and afforded a slight shade as the
Sun moved across the heaven as the day
progressed the ground lost some of its
stickiness and seemed likely to dry
sufficiently for travelin purposes in a
short time that night I slept but a
little and the next day I made myself a
pack containing food and water
preparatory to an overland journey in
search of the vanished sea and possible
rescue
on the third morning I found the soil
dry enough to walk upon with ease the
odor of the fish was maddening but I was
too much concerned with graver things to
mine such a slight evil and set out
boldly for an unknown goal all day I
forged steadily westward guided by a
faraway hummock which rose higher than
any other elevation on the roll in
desert that night I encamped and on the
following day still traveled towards the
hammock though the object seemed
scarcely nearer than when I first
aspired it and by the fourth evening I
attained the base of the mountain which
turned out to be much higher than it
appeared from a distance an intervening
valley setting out in sharper relief
from the general surface too weary to
ascend I slept in the shadow of the hill
I know not why my dreams are so wild
that night but either way kneeling
fantastically gibbous moon had risen so
far above the eastern plain I was
awaking cold perspiration determined to
sleep no more such visions that I had
experienced were too much for me to
endure once again and in the glow of the
moon I saw how unwise I had been to
travel by day without the glare of the
Parchin Sun my journey would have cost
me less energy indeed
I now felt quite able to perform the
ascent which had deterred me at sunset
picking up my pack I started for the
crest of eminence I have said that the
unbroken monotony of the rolling plain
was a vague source of horror to me but I
think my horror was greater when I
gained the summit of the mound and
looked down on the other side into an
immeasurable pit or Canyon who's black
recesses the moon had not yet soared
high enough to loom I felt myself on the
edge of the world peering over the rim
into the fathomless chaos of eternal
night through my terror and curious
reminiscences of Paradise Lost and of
Satan's hideous climb through the
unfashionable ooon climbed higher in the
sky I began to see that the slopes of
the valley were not quite so
perpendicular as I had imagined ledges
and outcroppings of rock a four did for
fairly easy footholds for a descent
whilst after a drop of a few hundred
feet the declivity became very gradual
merged on by an impulse that I cannot
definitely analyse I scrambled of
difficulty down the rocks and stood on
the gentle slope beneath gazing into the
Stygian deeps were no light had yet
penetrated all at once my attention was
capped
goodbye avast singular object on the
opposite slope which rose steeply about
a hundred yards ahead of me
an object that gleamed Whitely in a
newly bestowed rays of the ascending
moon that it was merely a gigantic piece
of stone my soon assured myself but I
was conscious of a distinct impression
that his contour and positioning were
not altogether the work of nature a
closer scrutiny filled me sensations
that I cannot express for despite its
enormous magnitude and its position in
an abyss which had yawned at the bottom
of the sea since the world was young I
perceived beyond a doubt that the
strange object was a wall shaped
monolith whose massive bulk had known
workmanship and perhaps the worship of
living in thinking creatures dazed and
frightened yet not of a certain thrill
of a scientists or an archaeologists
delight I examine my surroundings more
closely the moon now near the zenith
shone weirdly and vividly above the
tower and steeps had hemmed in the chasm
and availed the fact that a far-flung
body of water flowed at the bottom
winding out of sight in both directions
an almost lapping at my feet as I stood
on the slope across the chasm the
wavelets washed the base of the
cyclopean monolith on her surface I
could now trace both inscriptions and
crude sculptures the writing was in a
system of hieroglyphics unknown to me
and unlike anything I'd ever seen in
books consistent for the most part of
conventionalized aquatic symbols such as
fishes eels octopi crustaceans molluscs
and whales several characters obviously
represented marine things which were
unknown to the modern world
but whose decomposing forms I had
observed on the ocean risen plane it was
the pictorial carving however that did
most to hold me spellbound plainly
visible across the intervening water on
accounts of their enormous size were an
array of Bath's reliefs whose subjects
have excited the envy of dory I think
that these things were supposed to
depict men at least a certain sort of
men though the creatures were shown to
sportin like fishes in the waters of
some marine grotto or paying homage to
someone on a thick shrine which appeared
to be under the waves as well of the
faces and forms I dare not speak in
detail for the mere remembrance makes me
grow faint grotesque beyond the
imagination of a pole or a bowl though
they were damnably human in general
outline despite webbed feet and hands
shaaka knee wide and flabby lips glossy
and bulging eyes and other features far
less pleasant to recall curiously enough
they seemed to have been chiseled badly
out of proportion of their scenic
background for one of the creatures were
shown in the act of killing a whale
represented as but little larger than
himself I remarked as I say the
grotesqueness and strange size but in a
moment decided that they were merely the
imaginary gods of some primitive or
seafaring tried some tribe whose last
descendant had perished
IRA's before the first ancestor of the
Piltdown or the Neanderthal man was born
or struck at this unexpected glimpse
into the past beyond the conception of
the most daring anthropologist I stood
there musing whilst the moon cast queer
reflections on a silent Channel before
me then suddenly I saw it with only a
slight turn in to mosque its rise to the
surface the thing slid into view above
the dark waters vast polymethyl I can
loosen it darted like a stupendous
monster to the monolith about which it
flung his gigantic scaly arms all the
while bound its hideous head and gave
vent to certain measured sounds I think
I went mad then of my frantic ascent of
the slope and cliff and of my delirious
journey back to the stranded boat
I remember little I believe I sang a
great deal
I have indistinct recollections of a
great storm some time after I reached
the boat at any rate I know that I heard
peals of thunder and other tones which
nature utters only in the wildest moods
when I came out of the shadows I was in
a San Francisco Hospital bought thither
by captain of an American ship which had
picked up the boat in the middle in my
delirium I had said much but found that
my words were given scant attention I've
only learned upheaval in the Pacific my
rescuers knew nothing nor did I seem it
necessary to insist upon a thing which I
knew they could not believe once I sort
out a celebrated ethnologist and amused
him of particular questions regarding
the ancient Philistine legend of Dagon
the fish god but soon perceiving that he
was hopelessly conventional I did not
press my inquiries it is at night
especially when the moon is gibbous and
waning that I see the thing I tried
morphine but the drug has given me only
transient surcease
and has drawn me into its clutches as a
hopeless slave so now I am to end it all
I have been written a full account for
the information or the contemptuous
amusement of my fellow man often I ask
myself if it could not have been pure
fantasy ism and their freak of fever As
I Lay son stricken and Raven in the open
boat after my escape from the German man
of war this I asked myself but ever does
they come before me a hideously vivid
vision in reply I cannot think of the
deep sea of out shuddering are the
nameless things I may at this very
moment to be crawlin and floundering on
its slimy bed worship in their ancient
stone idols and carving their own
detestable likeness on submarine
obelisks and water soaked granite I
dream of a day when they may rise above
the billows to drag down in their Rican
talents a remnants of puny war exhausted
mankind over they when a land shall sink
in the dark ocean floor shall ascend
emits universal pandemonium and the end
is near I hear a noise at the door as of
some immense slippery body lumbering
against it it shall not find me and will
not let it God that hand the window yes
the window